[Música]
yo bailé aceptó oficialmente la
candidatura a la presidencia de eeuu por
el partido demócrata en la última
jornada de la convención que se realizó
durante cuatro noches de manera virtual
el exvicepresidente prometió sacar al
país de la crisis sanitaria y económica
de vido según señaló a las malas
decisiones de donald
ya son más de 250.000 las víctimas
fatales que dejó el coi 19 en américa
latina'
seis meses después de su llegada a la
región países como brasil perú méxico y
colombia están en la lista de los más
afectados del planeta la pandemia
también ha afectado profundamente la
economía latinoamericana que podría
tomar años en recuperarse
y el gobierno ruso y dio a conocer el
parte médico de alexéi navalni en el que
afirman que no hay rastros de veneno los
análisis del opositor los médicos
argumentan en que su estado es crítico y
rechazar el traslado al extranjero como
lo había solicitado la familia tenemos
reportes desde mozart
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y del mundo aquí en las 24
bienvenidos de nuevo yo soy liliana
valencia en su discurso de aceptación a
la nominación demócrata el ahora
candidato oficial a las elecciones
presidenciales joe biden pidió unidad a
los estadounidenses para superar lo que
calificó como una época de oscuridad el
exvicepresidente señaló que su principal
prioridad será encaminar al país para
superar la pandemia de kobe 19 y aseguró
que donald kohn ha fallado en su deber
más básico que es proteger al pueblo
estadounidense en paralelo el actual
mandatario aseguró que los comicios de
noviembre serán los más fraudulentos de
la historia y añadió que si los
demócratas ganarán las elecciones
acabarán con el país
[Música]
eeuu se encuentra en un punto de
inflexión una época de peligro real pero
de posibilidades extraordinarias podemos
elegir el camino de estar más enojados
menos esperanzados más divididos un
camino de sombra y sospechas o podemos
elegir un camino diferente y juntos
aprovechar esta oportunidad para sanar
renacer unirnos
si ampliamos esta información con
nuestra corresponsal en nueva yor mamen
salam amén buenos días y cuéntenos
cuáles fueron los momentos más
importantes trascendentales podríamos
decir también de la última jornada de la
convención demócrata que vimos anoche y
cuéntenos
sí muy buenos días desde nueva york pues
sin duda el momento más destacado fue la
aceptación formal de la nominación como
candidato demócrata de haydn el
candidato lanzó su discurso desde
delaware un discurso en el que trató
todos los temas que interesan sobre todo
al partido y que pondrán en práctica que
aplicarán en los próximos cuatro años si
salen elegidos como presidente joe biden
entre ellos encontramos temas como
inmigración cambio climático economía y
también por supuesto la crisis sanitaria
que estamos viviendo yo voy de puso
encima de la mesa soluciones prácticas
como por ejemplo una norma nacional
sobre el uso de la mascarilla de pruebas
de kobe rápidas para detectar los
positivos en 100 horas serie de
soluciones para acabar con esta crisis u
otros momentos muy destacados también
como una fórmula bastante interesante en
la que vimos a ciudadanos sin líderes
explicar cómo se veían de aquí a un año
por estas mismas fechas con joe biden
como presidente vimos también un vídeo
en el que conocimos al candidato
demócrata desde un punto de vista más
personal
me mostraron cómo una persona empática
generosa que puede llegar a conseguir la
unión de este país vimos escuchamos a
sus hijos a sus nietos se rindió también
un homenaje a su fallecido hijo beau
biden que falleció con 46 años por un
cáncer de cabeza escuchamos también
antiguos rivales en estas primarias como
por ejemplo el senador por new york's y
por y brooke quien dijo que el apoyo de
joe biden a los derechos sindicales
acabaría con los estadounidenses con la
pobreza de algunos estadounidenses
vimos escuchamos también al senador
escuchamos también a la ex alcalde de la
ciudad de nueva york michael bloomberg
quien habló de economía y por supuesto
también destacar los reacciones por
parte del presidente de una trama a
través de su cuenta de twitter y en una
entrevista de 30 minutos con una
intervención telefónica en la cadena fox
mientras que se estaba celebrando la
convención demócrata
gracias mamen por la información desde
nueva york y también tenemos análisis
aquí en france24 para eso nos conectamos
con jose de bastos politólogo analista
político y periodista quien se encuentra
en washington justamente la capital
estadounidense
bienvenido a frank 24 sin airbag de
abastos y cuéntenos después de finalizar
las cuatro jornadas de la convención
demócrata para usted cuál es el balance
del evento y que se realizó de manera
virtual por primera vez en 200 años
y bueno sin duda un reto ante el
coronavirus realizarlo de manera digital
hay opiniones mixtas al respecto pero
bueno el partido republicano también va
a tener este reto de no tener una
comisión tradicional no creo que de lo
más relevante fue como se quiso mostrar
las diferencias o las presuntas
diferencias entre bailén como un hombre
abierto al bipartidismo que logra reunir
personas de izquierda pero también de
centro y buscando incluso a republicanos
que estén molestos o que no les guste el
actual gobierno creo que es haga salto
mucho este punto y también el hecho de
que se le dio muchísima importancia a la
diversidad del país no vimos voces de
afroamericanos y de mujeres en el centro
de la convención creo que también
resaltando la la creciente diversidad
que hay en eeuu bueno pero vimos también
que bardem instó a la unidad al pueblo
estadounidense para superar lo que llamó
una época oscura del país logrará esta
unidad entonces bardem y ese resultado
podría verse en las urnas
para los hindúes lo que están buscando y
realmente al ver voces como michael
bloomberg como decían como john cage is
el ex gobernador republicano es un poco
lo que está intentando la campaña atraer
personas muy diferentes para lograr la
mayoría de las elecciones y luego
intentar tener un gobierno un poco más
de unidad no obviamente el país está muy
polarizado e incluso si yo voy a llegar
a ganar con una elección muy amplia va a
ser muy difícil tener tanta tanta unidad
en el congreso como en el partido
republicano pero de cara a las
elecciones creo que si está buscando
esto tener realmente una alianza muy
diversa en su votación entre sus
votantes y bueno creo que es lo que
realmente subrayaron en esta convención
de estar abierto a todas las tendencias
que hay en el país bueno para finalizar
cuéntenos ahora que bardem es candidato
oficial que se puede esperar de la
convención republicana la próxima semana
bueno creo que vamos a ver un contraste
en el discurso obviamente bailén hablaba
más de esperanza de cambio de lo que
puede ser el próximo año mientras que
trompo seguramente intentará resaltar lo
más positivo de estos cuatro años y
exista sobre todo la cierta mejoría
económica que ha habido luego de
obviamente lo hago un importante por el
coronavirus intentar sacar algunos de
esos datos más positivos y también creo
que buscarán generar mucho miedo de lo
que puede hacer un gobierno de va a ir
borrando intentando borrar esta imagen
de alguien conciliador y más bien
presentándolo como alguien muy de la
extrema izquierda creo que son dos de
las cosas que veremos en la convención
republicana que creo que a diferencia de
la demócrata si tendrá algunos eventos
con más público no no no será
enteramente digital como la de 90 pero
igual estarán muy limitados por la
pandemia que estamos sufriendo pues
agradecemos la opinión de jose de vasos
desde washington y continuamos en eeuu
porque en libertad bajo fianza que hoy
estimaron un antiguo estratega del
presidente justamente de eeuu en la casa
blanca quien fue arrestado por una sobra
este jueves varón es acusado de
participar en un esquema fraudulento con
el que se recaudaron 25 millones de
dólares para la construcción del muro
fronterizo con méxico al respecto tron
dijo que hace años no trata con balón y
por mejor apoyarles
pronunciado y brevemente arrestado un
jueves atípico para este varón el hombre
a quien se considera como uno de los
principales estrategas de la victoria
electoral de donald trump en las
elecciones de 2016 había sido sacado de
un lujoso yate horas antes y connecticut
la fiscalía federal lo acusa de sospecha
de fraude y conspiración para lavar
dinero por presuntamente haber engañado
a cientos de miles de donantes que
colaboraron con la iniciativa privada de
nosotros el pueblo construimos el muro
esta plataforma surgida en 2018 recaudó
25 millones de dólares para levantar el
muro fronterizo que prometió donald
trump en su primera campaña presidencial
de acuerdo con la investigación banon y
otros tres detenidos utilizaron esos
fondos para sus gastos personales un
golpe para un hombre que hasta 2017
trabajo en la casa blanca y que según el
presidente ya no hace parte de su
entorno no he tratado con él durante un
largo periodo como saben la mayoría de
personas en esta habitación estuvo
involucrado en nuestra campaña trabajó
para goldman sachs ha trabajado con
varias compañías pero
estuvo involucrado en nuestra campaña y
en una parte pequeña de la
administración muy al comienzo banon es
el octavo ha llegado al presidente que
es arrestado procesado por la justicia
el proyecto del que hacía parte tenía el
objetivo de levantar 48 kilómetros en
texas al año siguiente el grupo había
construido 0,8 kilómetros en nuevo
méxico cerca a el paso
banon y los otros acusados se enfrentan
a condenas de hasta 40 años de cárcel
cada uno
en caso de ser hallados culpables en
california las autoridades informaron
que al menos cinco personas han muerto
en incendios forestales que han
destruido más de 142 mil hectáreas de
bosques y amenazan a cientos de hogares
las autoridades ordenaron la evacuación
de varios poblados en el centro y norte
del estado ante el rápido avance de las
llamas
además las columnas de fue de humo
afectan a la población de san francisco
no los mayores pocos abarcan los
condados de napa y sonoma donde más de
53 mil hectáreas han sido arrasadas
y casi seis meses después de su llegada
a américa latina' alcoy 19 ha provocado
más de 250.000 muertes y agravado la
pobreza y la desigualdad en la región y
amenazando con acabar con décadas de
progreso social y económico brasil perú
méxico y colombia sobre cuatro de los
países de la región que registran más
casos positivos de kobe 19 a nivel
mundial andrea maya nos cuenta cómo
avanza la pandemia en estas naciones
con más de tres millones y medio de
contagios brasil es el segundo país en
el mundo con más casos de ccoo y 19 sin
embargo la propagación del coronavirus
podría estar a punto de desacelerarse
por primera vez desde abril la tasa de
transmisión de kobe 19 se está
desacelerando en brasil según datos del
centro de control de epidemias del
imperial college de londres la tasa de
contagio en brasil fue de 0,98 un número
que indica a cuántas personas puede
contagiar un paciente infectado del
coronavirus los trabajadores de la salud
insisten sin embargo en que la aparente
ralentización no es motivo para suavizar
las medidas preventivas como el uso de
mascarillas y el distanciamiento social
pero es el segundo país de américa
latina en la lista de los más
contagiados a nivel mundial la nación
andina superó el medio millón de casos
positivos por lo que el gobierno
actualmente coordina la compra de 30
millones de dosis de la vacuna contra el
jove 19 con 5 laboratorios extranjeros a
finales de agosto comenzarán los ensayos
clínicos de la vacuna de la
de oxford con voluntarios peruanos
méxico está por detrás de perú en la
lista regional de contagios de 1 millón
211 mil 552 pruebas aplicadas para
detectar el coronavirus el 45% han
tenido un resultado positivo uno de los
golpes más duros para méxico así como
para el resto de países ha sido en su
economía el trabajo informal es elevado
y son estas personas las que más han
sufrido en los últimos meses
bajar la venta
de algún modo tener que cerrar colombia
le sigue a mexico en la lista bogotá
donde está el foco de la infección ha
tenido que implementar varias
cuarentenas obligatorias por localidades
lo que ha detenido los contagios
levemente médicos rusos anunciaron esta
mañana que no hay rastro de veneno en la
sangre del opositor el ex en aval y que
se encuentra en una unidad de cuidados
intensivos naval y se había sentido mal
ayer cuando tomó un avión que lo
regresaría a moscú desde siberia por lo
que la aeronave tuvo que aterrizar de
emergencia en la ciudad de homs la
ampliación de esta información con
nuestro corresponsal e moscú xavier
colás
la negativa de los médicos rusos a
permitir que alexéi navalni pueda ser
transportado a alemania para ser tratado
ha sentado muy mal en la familia y en el
entorno de alexéi navalni la esposa de
naval y julian avalaba se ha dirigido a
los medios de comunicación a la entrada
del hospital de homs donde está
ingresado
el activista ruso y ha dicho que no es
un sitio ese hospital adecuado para
tratar a navalny y que lo que está
intentando el gobierno ruso que es según
ella quien ha influido en los médicos
para que tomen esa decisión es que no
pueda ser transportado a otro país para
que en europa no conozcan la manera en
la que ha sido tratado en rusia naval y
que veneno tiene en el cuerpo
una tesis parecida ha defendido la
portavoz de la escena valley que ha
criticado sobre todo la lentitud de los
médicos a la hora de dar un diagnóstico
ha dicho que si siguen pasando los días
el veneno que hay en el cuerpo de
nabarniz se va a desvanecer y no se
podrá saber que fue o quien fue quien lo
intoxicó mientras tanto los médicos
insisten en que no han encontrado veneno
en el cuerpo de nava ni pero también
recuerdan que su estado es demasiado
inestable como para que pueda ser
transportado
y finalizamos con información del
continente africano y vamos a mali
porque la junta que derrocó al
presidente ibrahim abu bakr keita ya
varios de sus funcionarios establecerá
un presidente de transición que será un
soldado o un civil así lo aseguró en
entrevista exclusiva con tras 24 su
portavoz el coronel en mayor ismail away
quien además rechazó el término golpe de
estado por su parte la organización de
naciones unidas pidió a los militares
que liberen de inmediato al presidente
ibrahim abu bakr kate al ex presidente
ya después de su renuncia
así finalizamos central 24 ustedes
continúen con más información en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom y
información en inglés francés árabe y
español para ustedes quédense con
nosotros estos trans 24
[Música]